we begin with breaking news amidst the
texas flooding crisis a fire burning
this morning at a flooded chemical plant
in crosby is blamed on the disaster
police had evacuated a wide area around
the facility after its owner said there
was no way to prevent an explosion at
least one sheriff's deputy needed
hospital treatment after inhaling
chemical fumes the plant in crosby is
about 25 miles northeast of houston it
was shut down last week before harvey
made landfall david begneau is in crosby
he just left a fire department where
crews are assessing the damage david
good morning
good morning we are at the crosby fire
department about five miles from where
the plant is right now we do not see
black smoke in the air but we were able
to get a helicopter over the plant and
you could see flames and smoke that were
coming from it this had apparently been
burning for several hours the
rupture as officials are calling it
happened more than six hours ago behind
me right now officials with the plant
are speaking they have not been willing
to release
the number of chemicals that are being
housed at their facility the list of
chemicals they have not wanted to talk
about they are answering some questions
right now the bottom line is there are
nine
different trucks if you will box trucks
on the premises three have lost
refrigeration and one has ruptured
we saw flames and smoke above the
flooded arkema plant overnight emergency
response vehicles blocked surrounding
roads as the black smoke filled the air
under the cover of darkness there was a
chemical decomposition
chemical reaction
that resulted in a fire at that location
since harvey hit on friday this plant
has been filled with more than five feet
of water by sunday all the backup
systems had failed and on tuesday
officials ordered all homes within a one
and a half mile radius to be evacuated
in a statement the company has said
without proper refrigeration chemicals
at the plant will likely degrade and
catch fire
the fire will be explosive and intense
giving off a thick black smoke which can
be irritating to the eyes skin and lungs
now this crosby facility produces
organic peroxides used mainly to make
plastics on the company website safety
videos show what happens when those
chemicals heat up even a small amount
can cause an uncontrollable and violent
fire they should have had something to
stop it matt dempsey is with the houston
chronicle he has investigated more than
2 thousand nearby chemical plants that
are at risk for potential harm he says
the arkema plant ranks 21st on that list
the plant is flooded
your reaction is you're surprised at
what i'm surprised they didn't
neutralize the chemical
it just seems like the easiest thing to
do when you see that much water would be
let's neutralize the chemical it's more
important to get rid of our stock of
this stuff
and neutralize the threat than it is to
just keep it cool
so emergency officials are telling us
inside of each of those box cars are one
to ten gallon containers and inside of
there is about 36 000 pounds of the
material that is used to manufacture
plastic the flames were shooting 30 to
40 feet in the air
and there there are nine of them
remember one has ruptured and the
emergency officials told us a short time
ago we expect the other eight could go
as well
that's not what you want to hear right
now thank you very much david